I think the end of us the whole point
was like you don't know what it what it
meant it wasn't necessarily about them
breaking up was it about them dying was
it like we don't know what the end of us
really meant what do you see
two paths
tough choice
can you help me make it one season four
towards the end you have this experience
where you have this vision of seeing
your character and Monica breaking up
the end for the two of you guys so are
we going to see that play out as season
five kicks off there's a little more
clarity on what that was all about so I
think fans can be really excited to kind
of check that out oh yeah Luke Grimes
and Kelsey as those characters Casey and
Monica are facing major life changes
with a baby on the way and we can't help
but think Monica's new look is sending a
big message the cramps are getting worse
that's three weeks early is it possible
that in the Native American culture
a haircut could signify a traumatic loss
grief yeah I think you're on to
something there really so it isn't just
I'll try to dance around dance around
spoilers yes around that haircut well
yes I think it is it does mean more than
just a new do but I think um you know
what they go through changes them in
this um
you know really immense way that I think
will inform their place in in the family
and and what's next for the Dutton Ranch
what you're going to do first what do
you think I'm gonna do
you're all fired
Beth you're my new Chief of Staff Back
To Work Kevin is the gov now yeah I mean
this brings on some possibly great
opportunities and things and and will
strengthen the fight that he's going to
the extent to protect his land and his
family but at the same time I feel like
there could be a lot of complications
how is that complicating things amongst
the family um you know I think we're
sort of always in our own little world
right I think John becoming the governor
isn't uh isn't the first on our priority
list and I don't think it really changes
much for us especially because
um what we go through this season you
know we have a lot on our plate
emotionally and all these other ways and
so I don't I don't think that it really
changes uh removes the needle for us in
any huge way right right at first yeah
yeah we're talking about women we didn't
get invited to the party what we're
never anywhere we're just on our own I
mean but I'm kind of loving that too
there are a lot of cooks in that kitchen
over there you know what I mean
sometimes you just gotta step away yeah
yeah create your own family right I love
you
I just pray that y'all stay together
this season and I hope
you know you end up having two children
so we'll see how that plays out I don't
oh yeah big happy family
and even dog in the mix I mean we have a
dog yeah
but wait what's the best hot dog's name
now what's dog's name now uh it's it's
dog in uh it's I don't want to say a rug
dad just wants to call him dog and I
think that sucks pickled ass well the
Dog's real name is Luna Luna okay but
what's the TV name what's
the drama returns to the Paramount
Network Sunday and aside from
Yellowstone Luke has plenty to look
forward to the 38 year old is also
pursuing a career in music and will be
hitting the stagecoach stage next year
along with other big country artists
including his new co-star Laney Wilson
[Music]
can you please save her a ticket
[Laughter]
you and Lainey Wilson are performing the
same day so are y'all cooking something
up and Ryan Bingham from our show too
Sid you must be down on your luck
I'm out of money and I'm all out of time
and I think that was really just kind of
a happenstance I don't know about that
Lou I don't know but no I the only way
that I know Elaine is that she came and
played during our code bubble season
yeah and we have these events on
Saturday so that we could all actually
have something to do not just stay in
the house and she came and played one of
those and we all just fell in love with
her yeah I know a few things
are we gonna see some Duets woven into
the storylines I don't think you'll ever
see Casey sing I think that would make
zero sense if he just all of a sudden
started like searching it wouldn't make
it I mean okay that would be fun
yeah
sorry we'll talk to Taylor about it just
went to shopping wow so
no interest in the dance what was it
like having country artist Lainey Wilson
on the show this season oh my God she is
wonderful and just so genuine and she
really brought that work ethic from her
music to acting I mean she's great yeah
yeah such a like just awesome presence
to have around good energy just
sweetheart she's amazing and the
ultimate Southern drawl oh
and when she gets fired up it is
something it's next next level you're
tasting some new music yeah yeah I
didn't see that coming in my life I mean
I've always played music I've always
loved music and I've gotten an
opportunity to make some
um in a real way and I'm thrilled man I
just
I just want to make something good at
the end of the day we'll see what
happens how did that happen it was just
sort of like you know sending little
things I was working on to friends one
thing leads to another somebody hears it
someone else you know somebody calls me
and it just sort of happened it really
organically and and in a way that feels
like I mean I I kicked myself if I
didn't take this opportunity that's
incredible did anyone on the show help
you kind of
um you know kick start this I mean
there's some there's people that have
been really encouraging about it and
who've heard me play or whatever but uh
I don't know it could be someone that I
don't I don't know honestly I just feel
lucky and blessed and and I
how did this happen I don't know all of
our Cowboy dreams are coming true with
you I mean you know it's just like it's
kind of perfect here so what what do you
find to be serenaded right totally yeah
what do you make good looks music oh I'm
just I'm really excited for him and I
think it's it's such a I think a natural
progression
um I mean I've heard him dabble on the
guitar and he's he's really really good
I love Montana but I'm doing this for
our family we need to talk do this for
my father I don't do this for me how
much does Taylor give you guys in
regards to your storyline it's how far
out
um do you have any input into your
character's development
I think he loves keeping us in the dark
yeah really yeah yeah
I mean I think he likes us to experience
the way the audience experiences it and
I think he's also kind of writing it as
it goes as well I know he knows how this
whole thing ends because he told me that
but I have no idea what that is and I
actually like it that way it's a good
way to approach everything it feels like
you're kind of living this second life
you know life's that way yeah right this
is it
yeah I think so too what is something
behind the scenes that would surprise
fans I don't know I don't know I mean we
honestly we have like a really good time
yeah we're not as sad as we are
from time to time yeah especially like
we're always sad we're always got
something really bad going on and we're
you know we're just yeah but don't worry
about us because we're having a good
time yeah we're having spring
[Music]
thank you
foreign